[Music]
the exact origins of the cotton plant
are unknown
although archaeologists have unearthed
pieces of cotton cloth over 7000 years
old
through the centuries cotton fiber was
traditionally processed by hand
until the early 18th century when the
first automated processing machine was
invented
before cotton arrives at the textile
mill to be spun into thread and woven
into fabric
it makes the journey from field to bale
cotton takes about five months to grow
from a planted seed to a ripe plant
this harvesting machine called a cotton
picker plucks fluffy seed cotton out of
the plant's bowl
leaving a trail of burrs and sticks
behind
the machine empties the plucked cotton
into a tractor-drawn buggy
this machine builds the seed cotton into
a humongous rectangular block called a
module
a truck transports the module to the
processing plant
known as a cotton gin once the cotton
arrives to the processing plant
sticks and burrs are removed as well as
any lingering debris and seeds
a truck dumps the module into a feeder
which moves the pack seed cotton into a
dispenser
the ground seed cotton falls onto a
conveyor belt which leads to the hot box
the hot box mixes the seed cotton with
hot air
which allows the moisture to evaporate
making the seed cotton easier to clean
a machine called the wad buster breaks
up the clumps of sea
cotton by tossing it against a screen
loose debris falls through the screen
openings down a narrow chute
then the seed cotton moves through a
machine called the steady
flow which divides it equally between
two processing lines
[Music]
on each line the seed cotton enters a
burr machine
which grabs the seed cotton with a
circular saw
and swings it against metal bars the
centrifugal force shakes off the heavier
debris
the seed cotton exits the machine
through one pipe
and the debris through another
a large auger transfers the debris to a
waste
chute and out of the plant
[Music]
the seed cotton is ready for the final
stage of processing
a network of pipes feeds a row of
machines called
gin stands the gin stand separates the
seed from the fluffy stuff
called the lint inside each stand
are 116 circular saws which are arranged
horizontally
each separated by a steel rib the saw
teeth grab the seed cotton
and pull the lint through the narrow gap
between saw and rib
the seeds are too large to pass through
so it spins in front of the rib
then drops into a conveyor the lint goes
into a flue which leads to the packing
area
cotton seed is sold as livestock feed
particularly for dairy cows
it contains 23 protein 20
fat and 25 percent fiber
cotton seed is also milled into
cottonseed oil
a cooking oil that's a common ingredient
in salad dressings
and mayonnaise the cotton lint is now
ready to be formed into bales
pipes feed the loose lint to the press
area when it arrives
a pusher moves the lint into a machine
called the tramper
which shoves it down into a bell-shaped
box
once the box reaches 500 pounds of
cotton lint
a press compacts the lint
[Music]
and tie wraps the bale
[Music]
next a conveyor moves the bale to a
bagging machine
and past grippers which pull a sample
from each side
while the bale slides into a protective
plastic bag
the grippers deposit the sample into a
bin
technicians label the bail with an id
number
then open the bin to retrieve the
corresponding sample
then the sample is bagged and labeled
with the bail id number
the factory submits the sample to the
united states department of agriculture
where it's analyzed for fiber length
cleanliness
color and other criteria once the
analysis is complete
the bale is given a grade and processed
accordingly